The Joe Rogan Experience for everyone to
like guys started realizing while you're
there your story like the words started
getting around the green room and uh it
was one of those things like what he
just got out three weeks ago wrongfully
accused for 30 years and here he is
having a good time it was it was a crazy
experience to like be sharing the green
room with you because you could see
everybody like you became like the
celebrity The Green Room you know what
I'm saying like everybody wanted to hear
the story everybody wanted to talk to
you everybody was blown away by it and
by the the grace that you displayed like
the fact that you could be wrongfully
accused spend 30 years of your young
life in in a cage and then come out and
just be this wonderful fun guy having a
good time everyone's laughing having
conversations
it was beautiful
um I look I'm standing next to him last
night you know worried
most of the night because
you know we had got on a plane and that
was his first time flying in over 30
years
um
there was a lot of stimulation and
you know I could tell you that I'm still
in shock even sitting here now that
we're sitting next to each other because
I spent the last several years visiting
him at sing-sing which is
um you know not a great place things in
prison in New York
um but I don't want to throw cold water
on anything but
you know
there there's a lot of stealing yourself
for the moment last night going on that
people didn't see
from you
um I think for Bruce I mean there was
one point where we were sitting in the
balcony
um
watching a tell and by the way
congratulations on that amazing Club
thank you an amazing the comedy
mothership is uh
is really a dream for the comedians love
it the crowd was amazing it was just so
awesome to see so congrats on that thank
you very much how fun is David tell he's
okay my side hurts he's a master he's a
master but um we were sitting there and
some other folks came in and at some
point
uh you know Bruce kept looking over her
shoulder
and you know I realized that he was
uncomfortable and uh he switched seats
very quickly so that he would be side to
side shoulder to shoulder with them
I know I think I know why he did it yeah
why did you do that well I think in
prison you become accustomed to not
wanting people behind you right and then
I got this scar in prison from behind so
you're always conscious of what's behind
you um you know of course yeah no one
goes through that experience
unscathed right you come out with these
uh idiosyncrasies or these quirks that
you these defense mechanisms that you
developed why you're incarcerated
you know you're in an abnormal
environment for decades you're gonna
it's gonna have an effect on you
psychologically how old were you when
they put you in I was 23 going I just
turned 24.
and tell us the whole story what
happened
well
I was arrested back in 1994 for homicide
I think that everyone knew that I didn't
do this case at all everyone knew I
didn't commit the crime I mean I
literally woke up that afternoon because
my girlfriend wanted to change her
niece's costume
and she wants she also had a taste for
chocolate cake
so just imagine waking up to change a
costume for Halloween a child's costume
and then disappearing for the next 29
years of your life
right
and being being charged with a homicide
while the prosecutor involved in your
conviction
has a history of misconduct and it
wasn't until some 27 26 years later
that he finally gets arrested and gets
convicted former Queen's prosecutor John
scarper he gets convicted for the very
same misconduct that I've been telling
them about that he's been doing for
decades
so he would just find someone painted on
them
yeah he would concoct the story a theory
as he did in my situation and he did
this just to just to convict someone
yeah anyone yeah so it wasn't that he
was targeting you it just he just
decided it was you anybody that he felt
was involved in a criminal lifestyle or
in drug dealing it's easier to get
someone that has a history of being
involved in the streets
to put a case on him then it is there's
someone that doesn't so you know once
they find out that you have a record
it's easy to say all right well he did
this homicide what kind of a record did
you have at the time I had a drug I had
a drug sale prior to that
so that's enough for him to say okay
he's a part of a drug crew and uh you
know let's arrest him and lock them up
his this particular prosecutor his thing
was bribery
um he would pay off Witnesses and he
ended up not only getting convicted but
went to federal prison for it he was in
some of the worst penitentiaries in New
York
from Attica to
I was in Clinton Great Meadows
sing-sing all Maximum securities
or maximum security prisons way Upstate
and uh
and some uh
towns that are essentially
you know some you know a lot of a lot of
racism is pervasive in those towns and
the prison is the uh it's the only uh
economic development in that town so you
got brother cousins aunts and uncles
working in the same prison so you get
into an incident with one officer you
got a problem with the entire system
and that's just how it is when you go
deeper Upstate I mean borderline Canada
you know hunting down a marble and Great
Meadows and different prisons like that
so in the economy of the area depends
upon depends upon the prison because
there's really nothing there
but snow during the winter time and
farming
so there's nothing else there
so the prison is a driving force behind
the economy so everyone's there right
siblings so nepotism is you know it's
prevalent in these prisons
and one of the things that you you
encounter is that you know these it's
not just cold in those areas if prison
is a cold environment and it's up to you
to create your own heat it's a dark
environment and uh somehow you gotta
find that light you know that light
within yourself in order to um in order
to travel in order to you know to do
something with your life more meaningful
you know what I mean
um and it's difficult it's not easy uh
you watch guys
um you know guys you talk to today and
you know tomorrow they're swinging from
the light they're dead right yesterday
they were fine you know the next morning
you wake up they they've hung themselves
you know and and these are the things
that that you encounter day in and day
out and you still have to maintain a
sense of
a sense of humanity right you've got to
become you could either do two things
you could become bitter or you could
become better
I chose the latter because one of the
things I did early in my in conservation
was make a conscious decision
to not serve time but to have time serve
me
I made up my mind that if you were going
to have me incarcerated for a crime I
did not commit
then I was going to take this time and
use that cell as if it was an office
I was going to use that school building
as if it was a university
and every chance I I had to
just self-reflect and engage in
introspection and and and do the things
that I needed to do to protect my soul
um I was going to do it
you know and I made it my business to do
so and I started delving into material
that I probably would never have read
you know being in uh being a free man I
started reading you know everything from
you know philosophy books to you know
very very few novels but I I tend to
learn from the experiences of others so
autobiographies became my thing you know
from from Quincy Jones to Miles Davis
and and just continuously studying right
and then studying the system and what
drives the system and and why it has
become what it is you know from
education to
you know to to the whole system of why
educational system looks at a guy in the
third grade and determines
whether or not he's going to be caught
up in the criminal justice system as
early as the third grade right based on
your reading level
they can determine how many prison beds
that they're going to develop
these are things that most people don't
know right these like 50 of the
incarcerated people in New York state or
probably in the country are living with
dyslexia
so then so they're unable to to learn
you know the basics of Education like
reading and these guys go home and they
commit crimes over and over again
because they were never corrected in
these same systems that
were built on the premise of
Rehabilitation
on Draconian in that
they do nothing but you know steal a
person's humanity and allow them to
become or looked at as nothing more than
a number
right you got to wake up six o'clock in
the morning sometimes when they're
coming around they're asking you your
name and they're not asking your name
they're asking you you know your numbers
what cell location you're in
they're not calling you Mr Brian they're
calling you 60 cell
right and a lot of people begin to
internalize that
and lose their sense of self
and so I remain guarded and um
and try to maintain a sense of humanity
through my meditation
right through fasting every now and then
and just do deep introspection and
reflection for me that was the hard part
the easy part was education and learning
the hard part was introspection and
fighting a system
right not just a prosecutor or a court
but finding a system that was premised
on um
you know
oppression right that was premised on
into business a prison industrial
complex you got cheap labor you know the
13th Amendment says you allowed to be
enslaved if you're convicted of a crime
you see and so you know in a system like
that you have to find a way you got to
find it within yourself too
to Rise Above The Fray did you meet
anyone else inside that showed you this
path
yes
early on in my incarceration there was a
group of guys called the resurrection
study group
and it was founded by a guy named Eddie
Ellis who has since passed on
and what the resurrection study group
did was they developed this this program
called the non-traditional approach to
Social and criminal justice
and it helped them understand why the
vast majority of incarcerated people in
New York state came from at that time
they came from seven basic neighborhoods
right and these were neighborhoods that
were all impoverished
that were all plagued with what we call
Crime genitive factors from
you know substance abuse to dilapidated
housing to uh you know just poverty
right
um and so you see you see violence and
what I've come to realize is that
poverty is violence
so wherever there's property you're
going to see violence because poverty
itself is violence and so these
neighborhoods you begin to learn and
study and you begin to see that this is
not by accident
these you know these prisons were built
for a purpose
um
there's a saying they say you build it
they're going to come that's the same
thing with prisons you build them
they're going to come similar to the
1994 crime bill
that was signed by uh Bill Clinton and
authored co-authored by our now
President Joe Biden it incarcerated more
people across the country than in any
other time
right it perpetuated the three strikes
you're out
um you had guys who stole a slice of
pizza third strike he gets 25 to life
um we're looking at cases now where guys
this took 200 he'd been in jail for 20
years
some guy sentenced 70 years for armed
robbery
right all of these things come under the
1994 crime bill so you've been beginning
to see it as a system that was designed
to do certain things
it's a wake-up call for you and you
begin to say hold on man um
I fell for the Trap it's time for me to
begin taking a different route and and
begin to educating myself more and so
the resurrection study group these guys
steered me in that direction
it steering me in that direction and I
began to learn from another gentleman
that was a part of it by the name of Dr
Gary Mendez who also died
and he had a program called The National
Trust
for the development of African-American
men and what it did was help us restore
those values that we strayed away from
so this this is what got me on the right
path early in my incarceration